we're also following breaking news from
Washington today former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort reached a
tentative plea deal with Special Counsel
Robert Muller he is expected to admit
his guilt in order to avoid what would
have been his second criminal trial this
year Paula Reed is outside the federal
courthouse in Washington with all the
details Paula good morning good morning
this is a significant about-face for
president Trump's former campaign
chairman Paul Manafort who had vowed to
fight all of the charges that had been
filed against him by Special Counsel
Robert Muller a man affort was convicted
last month on charges of tax fraud at
bank fraud in federal court in Virginia
and he faced a second trial here in
Washington that was expected to start
next week and those charges were more
closely related to his foreign lobbying
work on behalf of pro-russia Ukrainian
politicians but after evaluating the
emotional and financial toll that a
second criminal prosecution would take
he has agreed to enter a plea deal it
appears he will plead guilty to
conspiracy against the United States and
conspiracy to obstruct justice in order
to make this trial go away now the
outstanding question is whether or not
this deal requires any cooperation
sources have told me that he was trying
not to have to cooperate at all we know
Mike Flynn he had to cooperate as part
of his plea deal Richard gates he had to
cooperate as part of his plea deal but
so far it does not appear that there is
any cooperation required on behalf of
mr. mana port so far no indication that
is just sharing information he knows
about the president or his inner circle
as part of this deal and that means that
he is still possibly could get a pardon
from the president Gail Paul let me ask
you one question so why would the
Special Counsel
agree to a deal if they couldn't use it
to get leverage to get information out
of him and then also having pled manna
fort still faces some kind of penalty
for the things he's pled to right
absolutely and he's already been
convicted in Virginia so he hasn't been
sentenced yet for that case but he
already faces likely the rest of his
life in prison if he is not pardoned so
for the special counsel for any
prosecutor really it's just how you want
to sort of allocate your resources they
only have so much manpower so much money
so much time and for them a second
prosecution of the same person who they
had are
got a partial conviction for just wasn't
worth it all right Paula thanks so much